we finally have a picture of the black  hole at the center of our galaxy that  just looks like a blurry donut what's  the big deal black holes don't emit or  reflect light and take up very little  space despite being massive that makes  it incredibly difficult to image a black  hole but by combining the power of  telescopes around the world to make one  really really big telescope you can  capture an image of a black hole shadow  on the gas and plasma swirling around it  that's what the event horizon telescope  did to capture this image of sagittarius  a star the black hole at the center of  our milky way it took 3.5 petabytes of  data the equivalent of 100 million tick  tock videos to piece together the  picture sagittarius a star was  especially difficult to capture because  it flickers and flares every few minutes  the image confirms that our black hole  is four million times the mass of the  sun and could help scientists understand  how black holes work that's pretty  impressive